- UH... OH, YES.
GREAT.
OH, GOT IT.
- [coughing]
- WHO'S THERE?
HELLO.
IS SOMEONE THERE?
LISTEN, I'M ARMED AND I'VE GOT
AIDS, SO IT'S NOT WORTH IT.
- WHAT?
OKAY, WHAT THE HELL
IS GOING ON HERE?
- OH, ALLISON.
HEY, LISTEN,
THESE--THESE ONESIES.
THEY'RE MAKING ME BREAK OUT.
I CAN'T REALLY SEE ANYTHING.
I GOT TO GO TO THE HOSPITAL.
- SEE, I JUST GOT A CALL
FROM MONTEZ.
SAYS THAT JILLIAN IS GOING
AROUND FIRING PEOPLE.
- WELL, YEAH. SHE IS.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
RUDY SAYS, "WHEN YOU LEAVE
THE THIRD STRING KICKER
IN THE QUARTERBACK'S POSITION,
SOMEONE'S GONNA GET SACKED."
- OKAY. JUST SHUT UP
AND FOLLOW ME.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
- OKAY. WOULD YOU TAKE
MY HAND ACTUALLY?
- HEY, ALICE, HOLD UP.
- WHAT?
- ONE THING RIGHT QUICK.
- WHAT'S UP?
- ADAM, GET DOWN FROM THERE
RIGHT NOW.
- I DON'T HAVE TO LISTEN
TO ANYTHING YOU HAVE TO SAY
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE,
WHICH IS ABOUT TO END
BECAUSE YOU FIRED ME, ALICE.
SO HEAR ME, WORLD, 'CAUSE
THESE ARE MY LAST WORDS.
IF YOU TAKE ANYTHING FROM ADAM
"THE TOP GUN" DEMAMP'S LIFE,
TAKE THIS.
TAKE IT SLEAZY.
AND I'M OUT.
WRITE THAT DOWN.
"TAKE IT SLEAZY AND I'M OUT"
ARE MY LAST WORDS.
AND I'M KILLING MYSELF.
- WHAT THE HELL DOES
ANY OF THAT EVEN MEAN?
- TAKE IT SLEAZY!
- [thuds]
- OH, NO!
OH, ADAM! OH, NO!
WHY WOULD HE--
THIS IS YOUR FAULT!
YOU SHOULD'VE PUT ME IN CHARGE.
- HEY. IT'S A DUMMY,
YOU BLIND IDIOT.
- WAIT, WHAT?
both: WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN HERE
WAS NOT REAL.
THIS WAS A DEMONSTRATION OF WHAT
STRANGE TURNS LIFE CAN TAKE
WHEN THE POWERS THAT BE MAKE
DUMB DECISIONS...
- ...STUPID
DECISIONS.
DUMB DECISION?
- STUPID DECISIONS.
both: SO PUT YOUR FEARS ASIDE,
FOR ADAM IS ALIVE.
- HEY.